[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
joseph à 12 ans il habite le quartier
des halles joseph n'est pas parti en
vacances
que peut-il faire à paris au mois de il
y à beaucoup d'enfants qui comme josette
et partent pas en vacances
alors on a créé les centres aérés le
matin les enfants retournent à l'école
monde dans les bus joue dans les bois et
reviennent le soir vers 6 heures
[Musique]
les parents de joseph n'ont pas pu
l'envoyer en vacances cette année
joseph a sept frères et soeurs
les aînés travaille le père guy garnier
dans la famille on part à tour de rôle
en vacances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu faisais pas en ateliers
jeux flash après tu nous centrer tutorat
conseil dernière riches à stella plage
qu'est ce que tu faisais presque
toujours là et se baigner
tu t'étais part en vacances j'ai parti
comme en vacances ont trait à la
d'autres enfants oui tout en colonie
riche et aventure est en vacances
[Musique]
c'est maintenant le moment de la journée
quand joseph attendent
il aime le foot et c'est le meilleur
endroit pour s'entraîner ici
[Musique]
mais à part le foot qu'est ce que vous
faites au centre aéré ont fait des des
jours des cheveux courts dits balade
juste beaucoup de malades en fait
beaucoup de balles la démence et je n'ai
jamais fait
[Musique]
youri pleuvait non oui vous avez fait
les parties dans une salle d'un château
puis on a fait des jeux dans le château
le château prenez un d'accord alors dit
chiche
vous êtes le jeu
[Musique]
on
il
en ce moment tu préfère être dans la rue
ou à tout ça
[Musique]
et là je encore si avec mes camarades
tous mes camarades de chambre est muette
dans l'autre sens
s'il y avait une caméra où ils sont des
gamins vol en vacances
[Musique]
qu'est ce que nous ferons partie de vos
chars galerie smooth en mousse un jeu
près le gardien que vous faites quand je
bonjour à charmes à 15 des fléchettes
content qu'il lui dirait contre nous
contre les chocs latins le premier venu
là comme on peut le caresser
il reçoit une pochette oui pourquoi
contre les gens pour nous amuser un peu
et ton quartier je crois que damon n'est
pas tenue puisque derrière c'est la
maison qui a commencé à secouer ses
dernières cartes et de lancer dans le
pâté
le magazine du parti communiste
l'humanité
un mirage été bien sages à l'image
humain je me disais ma balade dans les
rues tu as de l'argent quelques fois oui
combien d'argent je savais pas
jeune déterminé quand tu as beaucoup
d'argent tu as combien ont ils one
comment tu les as je mets des bruits
comment tu te débrouilles conseillers
des bouteilles en aller en allant
chercher des chômeurs de shunra que des
feuilles de chou pour les lapins y'a
qu'à regarder
ça c'est bon résultat pour le gibier est
potes
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour et merci
voilà sans cela pour soulager seul à
l'approché oui quand vous jouez dans la
rue ensemble dimanche toute la bande
comment vous décidez des jeux passe dans
la rue d'abord je un après on fait ça on
voit toutefois comme sacrée non c'est le
bleu ceux qui veulent jouer on enlève ce
langage au foot
le nombre le nombre de berceaux kembo
fou de lui et là on décide par la
majorité d'accord
[Musique]
joseph va souvent au centre aéré sa mère
c'est qu'il y mange bien qu'il y a de
l'espace
et puis il s'y est fait d'accord je vais
le faire et pour le foot c'est tout de
même mieux
[Musique]
il appelle fiche ouais il trouve les
j'ai choisi les chefs suivant l'âge il
agit des garçons ne seraient pas traités
moi ça m'a bien non pas de voter mais de
dire des jeux de dire et qu'on les fasse
mais quand vous n'avez pas besoin de
rêver quand c'est dimanche par exemple
bien c'est la belle oui mais
[Musique]
dès que mon vélo sera bahreïn ou encore
je suis malade et intérêts
peut-être bien sûr la vidéo contient
granville ans les 5,5 tomber tout le
temps c'est un beau coup de coeur commun
[Musique]
et la manifestation pour que pour que
l'impériale d'être détruits et ils ont
été comme un étui toutes les
manifestations oui qu'est ce que tu
disais ce qu'ils disent et les étudiants
pour inscrire c'est tout le monde
les crs cette jeune et plus compliqué
fallait partir de partis loin je suis
comme un respect et qu'est ce que tu as
fait alors c'est très bon joueur mais
c'est comme ça ils m'ont pris pour un
passant l'a j'ai regardé de plusieurs
dégâts je la jette à côté et kouassi
fossard que sa tâche est réparé son
erreur quand ils sont juste à côté un
peu
l'une à 7014 d'avoir beaucoup de valeur
mais bon ça pourquoi tu aimes bien
visiter les musées
parce qu'on découvre des choses c'est
quelque chose d objets d des êtres
humains
des êtres humains dans les musées oui
dsk suppression préfère par exemple on
découvre l'affreux fugueur de richesse
voilà même sans quitter sa ville joseph
à l'état de choses à faire pendant les
vacances
visiter des musées aller jouer dans les
jardins publics se balader le long de la
seine découvrir d'autres quartiers
pendant quelques semaines
paris lui appartient cas d'être là bas
pas sûr
je me trompe pas je n'en ai jamais avoir
jamais assez que je n'ai pas de ça mais
la note
notre offre va devoir chercher sa lancée
sans atout si tu continues tu la connais
un peu la balle au bond il aime jouer le
passé des champions 50 jeux téléchargés
avec sa mine rome parce que cet été nous
ou d'afrique au couteau était joignons
oui toujours là voilà là au fond peuvent
toujours se dire aïe aïe aïe aïe jeune
encore
non
joseph on imagine qu aujourd'hui je te
donne un peu d'argent
qu'est-ce que tu ferais si j'achète pas
à l'onu c'est clément jammes sept autres
manches et à la piscine au 6 mai à ton
avis que ce qu'il ya dans musée grévin
des statuts ans et oui le statu quo qui
décrocha
[Musique]
on
nous
[Musique]
m
je
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
vous émettez
j'ai commis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la barre est d'abord
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est les vacances
c'est quoi ces patients apprécient les
vacances tu te sens très en forme wii et
tes camarades qui sont partis en
vacances ils sont comme toi est rentré
pour composer quoi poser ils soient
leurs compagnes un one est irrespirable
mire supra mystique mais toi quand tu
vas à vincennes c'est déjà la campagne
on peut pallier à la campagne
c'est déjà bien mais on ne peut pas dire
que sarko la compagnie ya pas de crème
c'est pas comme la copa n'y a pas de
faire mais pas de vache et pas d'animaux
domestiques et aurait envie de yajour
dans une ferme
oui faut bien un fédérer
[Musique]
quand il pleut et je peux aller chez
matin que je prends le métro
et puis pour autre chose c'est oui
cochez éloignés quand il ya un mariage
un baptême une communion 20 ans mais
trop et tu aimes bien nous serons chiche
au ralenti qui pleure ou en outre déjà
brisé en voiture même famille dans paris
je me lève un braqueur de me vient non
j'aime beaucoup
on connaît la compagnie
pour
[Musique]
si un jour tu avais énormément d'argent
par exemple sur mes choix
qu'est ce que tu fais c'est la belle vie
alors je manger au restaurant
je suis dingue quand même des histoires
à mes parents je m'achète un vélo non un
solex
[Musique]
suis je me paye dommage ou cinéma je
pense que reste cinéma avec mon frère
aussi créé à ces dates un coin ouais je
lui achète un solex son vélo
[Musique]
la suite
elle a en fait
rien
[Musique]
à
les abonnés
yes ça c'est la seule tous à la cei l'a
pas fait
[Musique]
je pense
ce matin quand même si je suis parti à
la tour eiffel rôle j'ai rencontré bill
bill geddie pièce buzz c'est un
américain
il a une cadillac et tous les partis
mangeot resteront probable coup de fil
bazar l'on ne croyait pas ne croyez pas
avez vous déjà on aurait dû des
lilliputiens
à la rentrée les copains vont des tas
d'histoires à raconter
joseph lui aussi race et histoire
[Musique]